beginning of the year is a great time to
take stock of your finances and to
prepare for financial success in 2022.
joining us with some really effective
ways to do just that is david herpes he
is the senior vice president at credit
one bank david thanks so much for
joining us why is the beginning of the
year such a good time to really assess
what you got going on well i think the
first thing is is we're starting to
think about taxes
right so last year closed we're
preparing for taxes and that means
pulling out bank statements pulling out
our financial statements so it's a great
time to rethink our budget and so how do
you start that process because for some
people the idea of budgeting is not a
fun one uh and one they haven't
practiced necessarily yeah well for a
lot of people it comes off as
intimidating a little daunting but it
really it really doesn't have to be it's
really a simple process of writing down
what your inflows are what your outflows
are most people have a have a great
handle on their inflows they know how
much money they're making each month
it's the outflow
and and it doesn't have to you know my
advice is is get a copy of three months
credit card statements three months bank
statements go through them and most
importantly look for those reoccurring
subscriptions
it sounds very simple but sticking to it
i guess is the hard part yes yes and i
so i think once you started that budget
and you've written it down with it be on
no paper or a spreadsheet then rethink
about it every month you know the
trigger could be the first day of the
month the trigger could be your first
paycheck of the month and that can be
your reminder to get that budget out
that you started in january and re-look
at it one of the tricks you have and i
think this is really smart because i am
guilty of doing this i actually i'll
sign up for a free trial of something
for instance and then they say after
seven days or whatever it is you start
paying monthly and i never get around to
canceling the five dollars six dollars
whatever it is a month but that adds up
it really does so the average american
has nine recurring subscriptions
and 82 percent of us have at least one
so i you know when i saw that stat i
thought do i have nine and i had to
think about it and i'm a pretty good
budgeter so i think until you take at
least three months credit card
statements and bank statements you may
not even know what subscriptions you're
paying for yeah and i think and over the
pandemic a lot of us have added some
subscriptions some of us a lot of stuff
oh sure right yes because you're home
and they say hey a free month of
whatever right streaming service or
channel
yeah it's easy to do and i think i may
take that average above nine so i may be
kicking it up there what are some tips
when it comes to organization because
that is a hard part for a lot of people
myself included when it comes to
just making sense of all the credit card
bills or bills that come into your house
on a monthly basis
well i think um i mean if you if
if you're good with computers or at
least have some basic knowledge of
computers the the spreadsheet is i think
the the best approach so you you get
your monthly statement uh you've created
the budget beginning of the year now i'm
going to take that statement and see if
anything has changed so one thing to
remember is subscriptions aren't always
monthly okay some are quarterly
some are annual yes right so until
you've looked at a full year's worth of
statements you may miss something you're
absolutely right i've fallen prey to
that one as well where something pops up
and it's like what's up 25 bucks for you
know right it's a what is the most
common mistake that you see people
making when it comes to
budgeting
i think the most common mistake is is
not shopping around so another uh
interesting stat is is the average
consumer is paying
overpaying auto insurance 330 a year
they've been sitting on the same
insurance policy the same insurance
company for so many years but if they
just spent some time shopping around
they could save some considerable money
a lot of money all right david herpes
from credit one bank thanks so much for
joining us great advice really